how's it going raise money welcome to
totally accurate toilet simulator so I
am sitting on a toilet huh okay this is
great
I couldn't have just [ __ ] brought a
camera to my toilet apparently I don't
have an [ __ ] which is kind of a shame
that's like one of the big necessities
we do I have toilet paper which I'm very
happy about and I can spin on the
[ __ ] toilet
I don't know about you bros but I I like
to spend a lifetime press one to do
number one well that makes sense I guess
alright okay I like to pee a little bit
every every once in a while yeah you
could think you could mistake this for
number two if you had some Mexican food
you could make that this channel just
took a dark turn so [ __ ] stupid this
is what you bro suggested by the way I
did not say hey anyway [ __ ] do you bros
ever do this we call this the machine
gun to to do number two okay now what
I'm curious about if I can do both at
the same time yes I'm a sad man okay I'm
having fun
look at this Jen yeah you know I'm gonna
I might be out of line when I say this
but I think this might be a little
better than call of duty
Call of Duty gameplay might I might be
out of lining when I say this stupid I
but I think this game has a little
better story the story than Call of Duty
too
this is so stupid this is so stupid but
at the same time it's less stupid than
all this all right
so there's a mother simulator game
imagine brother Yesod called robot
vacuum simulator 2013 you will mode what
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] wait I can control
I can play this co-op oh my [ __ ] god
playing vacuum simulator robot with
myself that's depressing
if this oculus rift support because I
want this to be as realistic it's
[ __ ] possible
I wouldn't recommend this game to anyone
unless I heard anyone say men I wish I
was a robot vacuum simulator and this
game is for you this is [ __ ]
depressing it just makes you think like
what the [ __ ] am I doing with my life
oh what's happening whoa this game oh my
God all the tired of control
oh [ __ ] oh Jenna's going forward and I'm
like clicking forward oh [ __ ] Wow Wow
holy Sh Oh alright I think I came I pick
up another one I don't know if my body's
ready okay well that's about much as fun
as I'm gonna have with AK [ __ ]
alright just when you thought there
wasn't enough [ __ ] simulator games to
play it's one is called curtain
simulator
ah ah why why oh man those curtains ah
oh man those Cardinals are so real
move your mouse vigorously around the
screen realize the curtains has ripped
think you broke the program keep moving
your mouse vigorously around the screen
click the mouse think you broke it
go to step one that is all right it's
beautiful is up yeah it did broke the
game what the [ __ ] I don't know why you
guys are so unhappy but this game is the
[ __ ]
Oh what the [ __ ] [ __ ] house that's
[ __ ] nasty so real oh my god it feels
Oh what what the [ __ ] Oh Oh take your
knitting a girl stop that second take a
[ __ ] went by her I made up some words
but that doesn't even matter girl cuz I
don't how that was me playing all the
simulator games [ __ ] fun not playing
any more simulator games
Rita Rita
Oh Tulare to strangers but it held back
- okay okay